russia's invasion of ukraine is
beginning
hours after russia recognized the
so-called donetsk in lohan's people's
republics as quote unquote independent
president putin authorized russian
troops to enter those regions he has
taken other steps that amount to a
direct assault
on ukraine's sovereignty
we responded and turned quickly and
decisively within less than a day we'd
announced the first tranche of sanctions
with our allies and partners including
those in the european union the united
kingdom canada japan and australia
our german allies yesterday took
resolute action to ensure that the
nordstrom 2 pipeline what had been a
prized 11 billion dollar investment on
the part of the russian federation
is suspended indefinitely and as you
have just seen president biden
today
authorized sanctions on nordstrom 2ag
and its corporate officeholders we have
now taken complementary action using our
own authorities uh to ensure that
nordstrom 2 is off the table just as we
said it would be
in lockstep with our allies we are
blocking from the global financial
system to large banks that are connected
to the kremlin and russian military and
russian sovereign wealth can no longer
trade on u.s or european financial
markets as you all know we additionally
sanctioned russian elites those elites
who are in many ways complicit
this is the beginning of our response
if putin escalates further
we will escalate further
using additional sanctions and export
controls which we've yet to unveil but
are fully prepared to implement with
allies and partners across the globe i
we what we have said in our what our
strategy has been predicated on the
knowledge uh that transatlantic unity is
the most uh powerful instrument we have
but i i don't but but look the
pipeline's already been built
okay now whether it gets turned on or
not is
is another right so you presumably you
had more leverage
and and i don't understand why you don't
think that you would have had more
leverage if it hadn't been if these
sanctions have been imposed
before the pipeline was finished so matt
you also raised a good point uh the
pipeline when this administration came
into office was more than 90 percent
complete
we have imposed sanctions under pisa uh
on uh a number of uh targets associated
uh with this pipeline persons and
entities uh but the fact is that had we
sanctioned uh nordstrom 2ag had we
sanctioned its corporate office holders
uh it is far from clear that that would
have
kept the pipeline from going into
operation what the germans did yesterday
was to ensure that the pipeline is no
longer part of the equation so by acting
together with the germans how we did
when we did and the way in which we did
we have ensured
that
this is an 11 billion dollar prize
investment that is now a hunk of steel
sitting at the bottom of the sea